rise and gr it's a new day full of New
Opportunities and new possibilities and
on today's episode of the coffee with
canel show we're going to be looking at
some smart strategies for creating
consistent YouTube success we're
actually going to start off by diving
into some YouTube analytics and looking
at some insights that will help you make
better informed decisions to improve
your content so you're going to love
that part but stick around until the end
because I'm going to be doing some live
coaching and there's going to be a lot
of nuances that I believe you can apply
to your YouTube channel for more views
and more subscribers to your business
leveraging YouTube and social video to
impact more people generate leads and
clients it's going to be a powerful
episode but I want to say if you're
watching on the replay welcome to
November we actually hit a new month and
this is always a good time to look at
your analytics and see what you can
learn and so for example what's kind of
cool is your YouTube analytics will
always kind of make a summary right
around the first of the month so we're
looking at October in total October 1st
through the 31st and this is my think
media channel so coffee with canel is a
think media podcast Channel subscribe if
you're new here hit like um this is our
podcast Channel we do these live streams
every so often but we're looking at our
main Channel and what's kind of cool is
you could see okay about the same as
usual on our views uh watch time down a
little bit uh subscribers about the same
as usual 33,000 in revenue and you can
kind of look across now what I would say
is you'll notice this Revenue still
processing check back on October 3rd
that's maybe an Insight you didn't know
that your revenue is always about three
days delayed so I suppose three days 48
Hours delayed nevertheless you could
still uh cut over to your Revenue Tab
and look back over your previous months
so we did 36,000 in September 37,000 in
August we're at 33,000 now it'll
probably go 34 35 over the next couple
couple days um and so then in a in a lot
of sense in one sense about three days
after the first of the month is when you
can get into your um analytics and start
seeing things I do think it's
fascinating to look at your top 10 what
was your top 10 videos in that period
and did something new pop on there or
was it old greatest hits of your channel
and then of course you can click through
and analyze nuances in regards to
looking at your content performance
performance overall just your shorts
performance just your video performance
lives if you're active with live streams
um what your posts on the community tab
are doing um and really review things so
this is just your friendly reminder
before we get into our first coaching
call here
to study your analytics because what
gets measured gets improved and you want
to make data driven decisions right the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over and over expecting different
results so if we look back over our past
month we can see what could we learn
what kind of insights was there any
breakout videos success leaves Clues
make part tw's should I double down on a
video topic that people showed extra
interest in um and in the future we can
also check out our YouTube mobile app so
just as a reminder if you have not
downloaded the YouTube Studio mobile app
that is a different app than the YouTube
app on your phone and it actually is
really a different experience the
YouTube mobile app really shows you and
I uh mine is updated so make sure you
update it um it really shows
you u a lot of cool insights and will
sometimes give you a recap it will have
like uh you know what happened with your
content this week it'll give you quizzes
there's a lot of interactivity to it so
if you haven't spent time in the YouTube
Studio mobile app I'm here on the think
media podcast uh mobile app forgive my
phone I I need to clean my screen if I'm
ever going to do this this but um
looking in here and going through what
is it that you can learn hit up your
analytics Tab and uh look through and so
here we go October this is my um other
channel this is this exact Channel
looking good your channel got uh your
usual amount of views understanding your
performance you can see that it says
revenue is still processing but as I
click understanding your performance um
it will you know give you different
breakdowns there's nothing here really
sensational for me at this moment but
again a powerful tool what gets measured
gets improved all right we are going to
dive into our show today let me know
where you're watching from and what are
you drinking I've uh got a little bit of
water here already had my coffee for the
morning um we're going to be talking
Deep YouTube strategy
today on the coffee with canel
show
[Music]
wow welcome back to coffee with Kel our
first guest today is CCE and Janet CeCe
did I get that right uh Jenna or am I pi
oh that skip to the second guest welcome
Jenna busy with dogs we'll start with
Jenna how are you I'm good how are you
thank you for having me oh so grateful
you're here thanks so much for jumping
on and uh tell us a little bit about
your YouTube history when you started
and what you're up to on YouTube um so
we are the channel is about 10 months
old now um and we're our history with
you is a lot longer we did grow with
video live back in 2020 when it was
online and uh we never actually started
a channel for various reasons and then
my husband got injured almost a year ago
and we he has been out of work and we're
like you know what let's just use this
time and we've just jumped in on YouTube
um and so uh busy with dogs was born so
w that's uh what I'm so grateful thanks
for joining us for Grow video live sorry
to hear about the uh injury but so so
cool to think about
[Music]
um taking whatever hand you're dealt and
uh and playing it and got a roll with
the punches got to roll with the punches
and so that's really inspiring so what's
your question today so um we have a lot
of different type of content and so I'm
just trying to make sure that every even
though we're doing various types of
content everything is cohesive and
serves our target audience which is busy
parents of dogs and kids so we have I I
actually wrote down a list of all the
different types of contents we have we
have talking head pupdates which is just
an update about the dogs what's going on
we got training tutorials regular Vlogs
tips and how-to videos we've got um
answering specific
questions um we've got our own uh box
opening spoof which is the hubby boxes
so instead of doing Bark Box we do my
where my husband surprises us once a
month so I I have no idea what's in it
so that's kind of fun um we do repurpose
shorts we do skit shorts we do training
shorts Vlog shorts cute moment shorts um
breed info shorts because you know got
to talk about the different breeds of
dogs um and we have a demo short and of
course we have reviews of specific
products I don't know if I said that
one yeah um and tell me a little bit
about your production it's
incredible uh so my husband um he
actually uh Works in or worked in film
he uh was lighting and electrician for
film so he uh has taken upon himself to
um do cameras we've got two cameras
going and um he's got a Gimbal and he'd
makes sure all the light eating is
spiffy and he's a musician so he's very
particular about the audio and so we've
been upgrading our mics and all that
stuff so it's like every you are always
saying you know get 1% better and I feel
like every video we're getting 10 %
better because we're just trying to
really give it our all yeah I can see
that so a couple things so I think
number one we can learn a ton uh for
everybody that's watching this from kind
of like the phases that you're in I
think the phase of starting good title
busy with dogs um channel name and clear
topic once you started listing
everything I I could definitely follow
but even without you listing out all the
topics it still seemed very clear to me
if I'm seeing um a dog mainly in the
thumbnail on the cover I get the gist of
okay is this channel for me or not and
it's going to resonate with people who
are dog lovers potentially dog owners um
and then I so I think the idea of
starting like for a lot of people
watching this you got to start you got
to start before you're ready you guys
did um for also then experimenting like
I think the list of video ideas you made
is cool but I think we need to go to
phase three now which would be Focus
you've been doing it for a few months 26
videos too so you've got a lot of videos
out there and also the phase of
improving production it's cool to hear
your husband's experience but everybody
watching this sometimes might even get
discouraged seeing your videos because
it's like oh man my videos they suck so
bad at the start and it's like yeah but
you can approve them as you go and so
you now have reached over 200 videos
five 400 almost 500
subscribers production seems dialed in
you've learned a ton you've made it this
far to me I think waiting for you as far
as advice I would give is getting some
of the right topics out there that are
going to lead to Big
growth um
and for example you know in you're Avid
in
V but like the pup date for example or a
vlog in my personal opinion has limited
upside potential in its growth right you
look at your whole list of
ideas and or the actual buckets of
content you're
creating from my experience some of
those just are probably not going to
blow up your channel so then you have to
make a decision but do I love doing
those do I love doing the pup dates for
the 37 people who watched you know one
of these most recent ones
do is that what I'm valuing or do I want
to go for bigger growth and I know a lot
of people in V struggle with this
because sometimes it might seem like uh
I I I you know I lean heavy towards like
review specific products and like
affiliate marketing um because you need
money for the mission but there's also
because they just lead to a lot uh they
can specifically when there are products
for it Niche and there are products in
this Niche and they can lead to a ton of
growth and money and new subscribers
that get interested in something like a
pup date a percentage of them might be
like oh I actually connect with you guys
and I connect and so to be more
specific
um what are some prod do you purchase
products for your dogs yeah so we have
we actually lean in on um product
reviews I have reviewed like three
brands of washable rugs because my
family is really hard on them um I
actually did a part two on a rug review
because the rug ended up being a trash
one one year later so that's the one
where it says it's trash and it's in the
trash can
um by the way and you probably noticed
this to that point your most viewed
video of all time is a product review
right so we uh the what what you must
know about new loom rug video like that
we have not just made part two we have
kind of dug into that and done other
reviews um on that the audience
retention rate is not as good on that
one as some of the other reviews um but
um I haven't made a single affiliate
sale from that video haven't gotten a
single sub but my other review videos
are doing they're starting to break out
of that mold they're starting to pave
more like this video did in the
beginning if that makes sense like the
tra the trajectory is improving we did
uh we have a wireless fence that I did a
review I actually when I was doing the
video I accidentally gave a demo and I
was like pull that out it's under 60
seconds let's make that a short so the
demo for the product is a short and it
has a related video link to the full
review and they're both staying like
right there with each other and um we
did make a a sale from that and that
one's starting I think that one's over
300 views now so yeah so here's here's
like if if I was G to if I was you and I
was going to make my next five to 10
videos I would probably I would
specifically make videos like this uh
best
dog
uh uh
toys um on
Amazon so
like I would look at something so this
is kind of like so success leaves Clues
so these are a top 10 reviewed dog toys
on Amazon 74,000 views is three years
old so if you did this video right um a
couple things could happen you might get
100,000 views or 70,000 views let's just
conservatively over a couple years it's
related to of course dog toys and then
in the description they're not even
doing the affiliate marketing so it's
some kind of weird channel uh but so
like that would that would be one what's
interesting is if you pursue a video
like that too I always like to think
about
how because I I mean this is think
media's whole model or what we've done
over the years it's like I would plan
ahead especially right now in the
holidays and I would like look ahead and
say like okay what are videos are done
nice I'd say like 10 accessories uh you
know or 10 you know for cameras and then
I would realize though that that video
might be able to split into four or five
videos because maybe it's like top top
three microphones under $20 those could
have been in the bigger list like it's
not always just like you have to make
one video so that whole like on Amazon
people wonder why does an affiliate
marketing convert well sometimes it's
about the um intent like here's another
one of these gadgets and this is this is
probably a faceless video which is
interesting because in your situation
you would probably think about having to
order the product and you would think
about having to test it yourself which
is all logical but I want people coffee
with Canal viewers to also see that
using OPC using the trailers of the dog
toys using b-roll of dogs and having a
voice over and having no personality or
on camera Talent this
Creator made a video that got 413,000
views has all the genius links to Amazon
links um and is not even in the video
and argue arguably never purchased the
product have you ever seen this before
uh I haven't seen that video but what we
did was um we kind of took the principle
of not having to order the product so I
recorded a uh video of your what's on
your dog's Christmas list and it's I
went through the hook is I went through
9,000 products on Amazon with that
search and I got a few clips of me
actually scrolling through with my dog
looking on Amazon and I looked at 400
pages and I condensed it down to this
many products so that you don't have to
nice um and so we've already recorded
that so we're we're getting into editing
it's supposed to be released in the next
week or two it's great and this is this
one's also I think these titles leave
clu Amazon dog products must have in
favorites so notice this Holly Channel
only has 12,000 Subs but 158,000 views
which is always a sign for me around
search when the views exceed subscribers
by the way that makes this video a lot
less impressive because this channel has
5,000 subscribers and it got 700,000
views on the video doesn't tell us
everything we really need to know
because you're like okay well even if
the video didn't perform amazing on
their Channel they have so many
subscribers the reverse is true down
here you're like wait a minute so Holly
made one video clearly that topic in and
of itself is bigger than Holly's
subscribers because she got so many
views now you would imagine depending on
what this channel is about she does have
a dog in thumbnail that she is um this
is also going to lead to subscribers
she's got her affiliate links here and
so this is there's a couple things I
mean I really like I always like RSP
review specific products I always like
the fact that eventually that'll push
you to monetization you got ad Revenue
you got affiliate Revenue but you can
get subscribers create that win-win win
but I think what I'm after is also just
thinking just the general idea that like
the pup date is not something someone's
looking for until they know you but what
they are looking for is maybe like you
know best organic dog food um for
example or best organic dog shampoo and
so it's not like your whole channel
would have to be taken over by reviews
if you will but right but no doubt about
it these types of videos are going to
attract dog owners that know they're
looking for a specific product right and
so and we're right around the holidays
which a click on your $7 dog toy if
someone buys it gives you 13 cents but
the click for 24 hours gives you credit
for anything they buy so there's a big
opportunity there right we're actually
revamping the P like we haven't leaned
into the pup date that much because we
realize that's
not um that's not how you get found
which is why we lean into uh I actually
used your trick a few months ago and um
where you type in YouTube something
about dogs and um so two video ideas
from that was can you have a dog and
work full-time so we did that video and
that video is doing pretty well it's
being viewed roughly 16 times and in a
48 hour period which for me is pretty
good that's awesome so we so we are
trying to really try to leverage in the
in that and um we're actually I've been
studying um this farmer that does
vlogging and he has like he tells a
story while he does his farm chores and
there's a lot of great editing and stuff
like that but he has one point and it's
s and it often is searchable like it'll
if he finds a swarm of bees all of a
sudden he's talking about what you do if
you find a swarm of bees which you can
search that but it's relevant to the
farm and so you still get those that
Vlog style but it's it's got so I've
been really studying going okay how do I
how do I do this cuz I do like the
vlogging aspect but we're pretty much
nixing the pup date as is we've been
slowly moving away from it go that makes
that's brilliant too Jenna the whole
idea of vlogging can we could be
constrained to it meaning okay it has to
only be random and you have to have
subscribers for people to be interested
no if you can weave in storytelling and
if you can have a singular theme um that
then the video delivers on regarding the
title then really it's just maybe a more
Dynamic way of teaching it's a more
Dynamic way of an experiential video
that can deliver similar to what a
talking head video does but in a much
cooler more interwoven with your day
well very inspiring so I think I mean
congrats on getting so many videos ahead
and um and also getting ready for the
holidays on the first of the month when
we're recording this November 1st uh one
it's one of the most powerful things for
our community to just just take this
opportunity to realign with your goals
to plan ahead for the next 45 days
because this is going to be a major run
and so even just being here taking the
time to get your mind right your goals
right your calendar right is there any
other question I can answer for you
Jenna as we land the plane uh yeah so
we're um we're quickly I'm already
planning for 2024 I'm like way like
nitty-gritty like planning um so we're
like I said we're planning on doing the
pivot but we're also thinking about
doing a podcast called Dog mom Central
do you think that's a good idea to start
in the beginning of the year or should
we lean in a little bit more in what
we're doing and maybe do that maybe mid
year yeah so
to with some final
advice I would not launch that in
January so as back to your list and it
felt like you listed like 10 different
buckets my question would be
like a rating and scoring program on
these different types of videos so you
could still be in experimentation but my
I actually think after 206 videos you
kind of graduate from experimentation
and you want to go into refining
refining down and
simplifying if you had to cross out
seven of the 10 buckets and you just
kept the three strongest which ones
would you keep not saying you have to
stop any of them but I'm saying that's a
these are good thought exercises if all
the different types of uploads you're
doing which ones perform the best and
are leading to the most growth because
the word that comes to mind is the word
focus and you've probably heard me say
it stands for follow one course until
successful um in my opinion until you
reach kind of like a critical mass
escape velocity momentum some of these
things are hard to Define but momentum
would be I got to get past th000
subscribers I want to get to a
consistent Baseline of passive income
coming in from affiliate marketing I
want to get you might even say 10 ranked
videos 10 ranked videos and and when I
say ranked it's like that many are on
your real-time videos I'm GNA wait until
I get Sean said get 10 ranked videos
first um and then you know so vid iqed
to have a really
good window they don't have the same
window anymore that would show you all
the The View velocity but now what it
does
is it
uh it's just got the little blue number
right here now so what I'm interested in
a ranked video is I'm looking for an
older video here's one that's a month
old um and it's the best hybrid camera
of 2023 versus we teach verses all the
time and it's getting seven views for
hour that's what's ranked for me views
per hour at least one view per hour 24
views a day would be one view per hour
so if we keep
going sometimes these videos are still
getting views but it's immeasurable like
it's it does it's not enough to show up
according to vid iq's counter but this
truth about YouTube automation Channel
14 views an hour so this idea of ranking
videos is this is how many videos that I
can just look at publicly here's three
views per hour here's one view per hour
I would want 10 of those on your channel
okay for this idea of like launching
something new that's what I want to
encourage you to be cautious of and
everybody listening before we launch
something new have you got the thing
you're doing right now dialed in
consistent you figured out what works
some money's coming in you're scaling
and building that up maybe one case
study to relate it to is you are
familiar that I started the think media
podcast it's about 3 years old now but
think media technically is 13 years old
but I went full-time All In on it around
2016 so I I did think Med I did one CH I
actually scaled back from having so many
channels and so many distractions and I
teach on it all the time
now around probably 2017 I got focused
on just think Media One
Channel and it and I waited three more
years until I launched another Channel
money was coming in was able to have
editor help all that other kind of stuff
so as exciting as it is to I Absolut I
think you could have conviction that we
want to launch a podcast and I think you
build up a fan base dog lovers they
would love to wa listen to that podcast
but to do that now You' just be diluting
your energy more it's like focus on
ranking videos uh particularly that are
bringing passive growth passive income
passive views um and in doing
so then you're like okay because I've
got those and then see what happens from
there okay and it's kind of like a nice
exercise that limits your expansion it's
kind of like if I opened up a coffee
shop um and it wasn't quite profitable
yet or it didn't have enough foot
traffic or not enough marketing had gone
up in my local town yet and it just it
wasn't quite there and then I said you
know hey I'm thinking about launching
three more of these one city over one
state over and across the country the
advice of the wise would probably be
like let's like let's get this first
store buzzing popular popping blowing up
marketed Word of Mouth everyone's pumped
about it we got enough money coming in
all right cool now let's expand and I
think that that principle could be
applied not even just to you but like
literally to all of us like before we
expand let's get our main thing
healthy okay sound good yeah sounds
sounds perfect thank you I appreciate
you so much thanks for coming on coffee
with KDAY oh by the way thank you for
the book that I won back in July
yeah uh you're welcome so I wanted to
say thank you oh so grateful for you
hope you have an amazing November and uh
look forward to continuing to watch you
guys grow well thank you thank you so
much take care all right we got two more
coaching calls today but so much coming
up first of all do you need to focus um
do you need to follow one course until
successful are you feeling a little
distracted I want to encourage you it's
November 1st at the time of recording
this it's a good time to get your mind
right to get your goals out maybe you
haven't set goals I actually truly
believe that you can accomplish more in
the final two months of the year that
than you did in the first 10 if you get
disciplined you get focused you get your
goals right you shut out distractions
you interrupt your interruptions and you
really dial in the details this is also
an extremely strategic time to be going
all in on uh YouTube and by the way
today's episode is brought to you by VR
podcast.com um that actually uh if you
haven't heard we have a special sale and
special bonuses going on right now for
our online course called video ranking
Academy now this isn't for everybody and
if if you're not interested no worries
but I know there's some people that have
been on the fence we actually only have
at the time of recording 13 hours left
it's not that's not false hype or
anything that's a real deadline to
specifically get um this bonus package
that we've put together including a
ticket to our YouTube roadmap Workshop
that is happening in January including
our AI for YouTube guide our Niche
Finder course camera confidence course
you could see all of the details um FYI
there's only 13 hours left at the time
of recording but I want to encourage you
this is a super strategic time to make
strategic videos uh on the count down to
Black Friday and Cyber Monday and like
even if you are like well I'm not a tech
Channel I don't need to do Cyber Monday
no listen if you're a dog Channel and
you rank videos now and people are
clicking on your affiliate links the
same day that they're shopping for Cyber
Monday why would they be doing that well
because they own dogs they're searching
for answers and things related to dogs
they remember they need to buy dog food
around November 26th so they go to
Amazon or they go to YouTube they look
what's the best organic dog food they
find your video you explain the five
different you tested and you review the
ingredients you then link that in your
description they click it and they're
like this is so cool and they buy the
dog food and then they land on Amazon
though and they're like oh wait Amazon's
doing a sale oh okay well let me just
let me just get some of the things I was
looking for oh wait a minute A PS5 slim
is on sale add to cart that's what my
son wanted oh the Weber grill is on sale
right now add to cart that's what my
husband wanted and if they click the
link your link for 24 hours you get
credit for anything they purchase so
this is actually why it seems like
probably over 50% of the revenue we make
at think media is from items we never
recommended well see this stuff doesn't
happen by accident we just reverse
engineered weeks ahead it's it's
strategic thinking we're thinking months
ahead weeks ahead let's make videos
today that are going to influence the
results we get tomorrow and so this is a
super strategic time friends to be not
just watching this stream um but if you
want specific help with that too so of
you were a part of our challenge um we
break down exactly how to rank videos
connect them to passive income You Can
Read All About It uh there's a link in
the description but uh you can join V
plus tons of bonus courses and more at V
podcast stands for video ranking Academy
podcast.com that URL is just a URL we
use here on the think media podcast
Channel um because uh so that we know
how you heard about V if you're a
watcher of the coffee with cel show and
all of those kinds of details now if you
got a question you can put forward
question marks before and after and I
think Drea will star those for me but
next up and I'll be getting your
questions here in just a
second next up let me bring up the
channel I think we're gonna be going to
CC oh we got him we got we got Janet CC
and CC welcome to the show sfmf how's it
going going great thank you very much
good to see you thanks so much for
jumping on tell me a little bit how long
you guys have been on YouTube and what
you guys are up to so uh about a year
now we started had the idea in November
kind of started to hit it in December
didn't know what we were doing um
technically or or YouTu we weren't sure
what we do know is that we we want to
start a community I've been I'm retired
now I've been a marine for many years my
kid we have five children they're all
part of it they're starting to to ask
questions a lot more now that I'm
retired and the questions they asked
that's what my wife J is like hey let's
document this get it out and continue to
build a Community Education knowledge
motivation camaraderie and it and it
stuck a little bit the shorts people are
very interested we get great comments
great
support U and now that we're still
learning after almost a full year we're
trying to decide on our Direction and
focus and how to
increase our our Channel and and get
more
people yeah I love that and thank you so
much for your service and uh this is
inspiring now long is it true that long
form videos though you've done a total
of
eight yes
gotcha so the channel is about six
months old it's about 10 months old yeah
it it took off we started putting stuff
onto it in probably January February
yeah gotcha well great job I mean
congrats on Crossing 10,000 subscribers
thank you um and a couple shorts here 4
743 667,000 so it's really great results
you've been getting there um what's a
specific question I can answer for you
so it again I'm I'm a big fan of the
shorts and I and I think people are but
I know to to reach more uh the
Longs is where we need to go we do want
to eventually monetize we have a bigger
plan later on to create this community
for warriors transitioning or trans
transitioned um into a again a big Camp
somewhere we're going to continue this
continue the channel continue to grow
the community to help veterans so where
do we need to Niche down I guess or
continue to grow
and where should our Focus be looking
for some guidance here gotcha yeah so
love what you're doing I think you also
your feedback loop of what's happened I
mean with the 21,000 views here even a
thousand on your long form some shorts
doing very well um clearly the the
demand for it is there you're resonating
with people already um and
so my initial thing is I think
visioning what does winning look like on
a on a big level and some food for
thought is asking what is the mission
and the purpose like what's the impact
and transformation you want to make and
then what's also the business model if I
was you um and if I was everybody
watching coffee with canel one thing I
do think about is one how can we use
YouTube to grow and Reach people but
then then also how do we move people off
of YouTube to our own Community um and
then also how can that connect not just
a deeper impact with them but how could
that also be related to perhaps the
finances that cover this by the way is
that g is that part of this are you
trying to figure out how to make this
sustainable so you have money for the
mission yeah absolutely that's that's
the the ultimate goal is yeah provide
but we need a ranch and we need yep
money to make money to you said you need
a ranch so that you can have training
facilities is that what you mean a
physical Ranch yeah yeah training and
again a place for Trans transitioned
service members that don't know what
they're doing yet don't know where
they're going and need some assistance
yeah your vision is beautiful and that
also the bigger the vision gets the
bigger the more bold we want to be about
the finances that we need to get there
and the cool thing about
entrepreneurship is we can bootstrap our
way um to there so what I wonder is
there's many models but the model I
really like would probably be something
along the lines
of kind of like a
Netflix you know to be more direct a
membership site
um
for veterans that holistically helps
them transform and reach the various
things that you're going to help them
do um the reason I say Netflix is
because maybe it's at that 10 or $20
month or $25 a month and then I like to
work back and think about how many
members would I need for monthly
reoccurring Revenue
mrr how much how many members would I
need to hit that first level of
Financial Freedom and expansion to make
the payment on the ranch to whatever so
maybe it's 10K a month 15K a month 20K a
month um and in doing the the math we
can end up saying okay so if we want to
do 20K a month divided by a $15
membership we need
members not too bad actually it's like
not that crazy to imagine that
1,333 people want to be a part of this
exclusive Community um where there's
that next level premium content when you
start thinking about numbers like that
too you certainly could do channnel
memberships like you could turn on
channel memberships eventually here um
which is YouTube's way of having maybe
an inner circle and you could release
content to them the problem though with
using YouTube's Channel memberships is
they take 30% so if you did get to 20K a
month they would take $6,000 which is
crazy um and so but you know cost to
doing business how do you want to set it
up so that's kind of the model I would
work backwards from is first of all
where is this all going now that it
brings up anything like that brings up
another 163 questions okay how could I
make that sustainable it's hard enough
to make the free content how could I
also make but
those the leader willing to wrestle with
those questions the longest and just I'm
going to I will un tell I'll figure it
out you know I'll early on I'll I'll do
it with my own Sweat Equity it's but it
starts making you think of questions of
like maybe I could hire someone to help
run that you know a virtual assistant of
some kind eventually that helps run that
and helps manage that to think about
scaling the Empire that it'll take and
you've got a big Vision so um bottom
line to oversimplify that whole piece is
trying to answer the question of how are
we going to make money in a sustainable
way and how do we sustain this in
answering that question then I would say
I mean to insert
another just example you could say uh I
want to build a brand and go viral like
David
gogins and self-publish a book like
can't hurt me and sell 10 20 million
copies there's your financial needs met
as well now that's tough to do um and
that's a unicorn story but nevertheless
this mindset of having something to sell
having the Commerce piece um because you
also don't start there we need to get
that built though because then all these
people that are coming through your
world some have a chance to actually do
business with you one way I've heard it
said is your business is
directly your income is directly
correlated to the amount of buy buttons
you have on your
website so I'll ask you and I'll ask
coffee with canel how many buy buttons
do you have on your
website and usually the response is well
I don't have a website so it's so that
it's like a few other I don't even have
a website let alone a buy button if I
had a buy button I could collect the
money but how would I what am I even
delivering and so it opens up like a
nice thought process but that's the
thought process you want to stick with
when you have figured
out a completed you know through line of
they can watch free content I want to
start a Discord group I want to start a
private Facebook group I want to start
Channel memberships I want to start a
free community there's a free level but
once they're in it they they can advance
to a pay level there a platform called
School Skol L there's kajabi so so that
in of itself is like its own segment of
research in doing so then now that we
know it's my book it's my audiobook it's
my membership site it's my private group
it's it's the thing I'm creating it's
the SF MF Elite program it's whatever it
is now you want to double down on doing
content like you've done but just
driving awareness
towards um that thing that you know you
have for a deeper level of
transformation for the people watching
and and you can I mean does that make
sense so far no it it does and a
question that comes up in it is when so
right now again we want Guidance just on
the channel alone to to get it better to
grow the community but I'm wondering
when do we start to in introduce our
goal to get byy in because I I I think
like you know a lot of people that
sounds great I want to support you know
veteran community that where
transitioning service members can go and
work but I don't want to turn anybody
away from what we were doing already so
same idea same same people doing it but
when do we introduce the fact that this
is our ultimate goal is this I mean I
think the sooner the better I think that
what this is making me think of is Step
number one for us as entrepreneurs
is get a vision clarify the vision and
then communicate the vision okay and so
I think communicating the
vision
if when you back it up as a leader of
character when
you don't quit when you not only
communicate the vision but you keep
communicating it and when your character
and consistency aligns with it that's I
in my opinion how Visions are built
meaning you say it right now with your
you know Channel as it's just getting
started and people might go like that's
kind of inspiring but yeah right and
then you're still saying it three months
later and you're closer to it and things
continue to build and they go man maybe
he's serious sure is putting a lot of
work then you keep saying it and and it
starts to manifest more and then they're
like man this person and like uh that's
kind of the nature of of building it I
think people follow vision and they also
in the law of leadership there's like
the law of the picture or the law of us
being the model of it people buy into
the leader before they buy into the
vision um and so buying into the leader
it's then it's like man I want to be a
part of this and there'll be people I
was talking some big Vision um related
to think media for years and we're still
not there but I think what helps build
momentum is progress one of the my
mentors taught me progress and
Improvement so cast The Vision big yeah
and then just continue to demonstrate
progress and
Improvement and big Visions require
years and decades to accomplish so I
think the reason to hesitate from the
vision is number one if we if we share
it prematurely or if we're not fully
bought in or are sold or committed then
I I think it's what we we're careful
what we commit to publicly but if you're
sold out so that means that the vision
is clear yeah you've clarified the
vision you're sold out into the vision
you're committed to the vision and so
long as your health permits and God is
willing you're not going to quit
building towards the vision then you
should communicate the vision because
even if critics are out there it's also
nice to historically put that on tape
like you put out a video you know in
this next C week and then you watch it
10 years from now and you're like see
ain't no believe in me back then but
like I I like I saw this thing so
clearly and so I think vision is very
powerful um when all of those
ingredients are
aligned good no that makes a lot of
sense yeah I appreciate that and if you
can answer one more um not I want to get
you in a a dispute between a couple
shorts or or Longs I love doing the
shorts and again I know the importance
of
Longs yeah well I think because your
Channel's not monetized right no yeah uh
Longs
are let let's put it this
way if I had to only choose one I would
choose Longs a 100 times out of a 100
yeah um that's also just how the math
works there's here's like 15 reasons
why one if I calculate the math Longs
actually pay my bills and shorts don't
even get
close uh two if I calate the impact
shorts give me a lot
of they stroke my
ego but because I get big views but do
they actually cause transformation one
of the things we were just talking about
in our staff meeting this morning was
also the difference between shallow
content and deep content and actually
including Longs I think content that's
on YouTube and on social platforms is
ultimately shallow that's why we sell a
transformation program called VR
podcast.com why we have our program
because we know that our best shot at
getting transformation for somebody is
when they ultimately join not even our
uh watch a long video when they join our
program video rank Academy which is 55
hours long that has a workbook that has
a community so that there's repetition
there's Mastery there's Community
there's the real impact on their
psychology and they're thinking and
there's real transformation that happens
when we casually and that is a
progression so shorts are at like the
most um empty calories level they're
good but they're I don't know how many
people will see in three to five years
that come to us and they're like oh my
gosh I'll never forget it was November
1st 2023 I was on my phone watching
YouTube shorts when a short hit my feed
and man that short so changed my life I
changed me as a husband as a father I
went from being broke to being a
millionaire I went from being lazy to
being disciplined I watched one short
like we'll see but I don't know if we'll
ever hear that story you know what I
mean like because the short also even if
it if it is profound and what it shares
in 60 seconds the fact the person
Scrolls on they're so quickly forgetting
there's and and hearing this people
could think I'm fight I'm arguing
against them I'm not I'm just arguing
that they're the most shallow empty
caloric level of
content um so not just the money also
the impact also the transformation um
and so I would not just pick Longs over
shorts I would pick um a deeper
transformation that's why I would
encourage you building out a community
for example when people pay they pay
attention one of the powerful reasons of
of spending our money and investing in
things is is it's even biblical it says
where your treasure is there your heart
will be also if we actually want
someone's heart to be connected to
building a business building an empire
getting disciplined really going and
crushing it
casual sideline living just watching
other people play the game and consuming
content is not where it's at you got to
get in the game right you got and you
you know this I'm pretty sure the choir
But ultimately uh that's that's what I
think about so I kind of
digress um you know Longs also can have
multiple ad spots they are really good
for teaching and trans because you could
do time codes and
chapters um so they're they're good for
people getting to know you they're good
for a little more storytelling a little
bit more connection they're good for
personal branding um but the real answer
is it's all good the question is a
prioritization question and a human
resources and a financial resources
question because when you're building it
up like you are like if you look at
think media WE Post 350 pieces of
content a week so our
actions evidence our values do we value
vertical video clearly we post a ton but
how do we do that team systems it costs
money do we post Longs yes do we post
ultr long videos and live streams we're
49 minutes into this one yes so we
actually hit a lot of different content
do we have an online course that's also
55 hours yes that took time to build
eventually it took a team to build it
took money to build we had to have money
for the mission in the first place and
we just contined to scale our impact so
I would highly recommend it's going to
get you to monetization sooner and you
have already evidenced that you can pull
3,000 views 21,000 views so I think
doubling down on long form if I was you
would be um something I would definitely
do awesome thank you very much you have
a
question no yeah thank you very much
Sean appreciate you thank you so much
really appreciate uh appreciate you guys
thank you so much for your service love
what you're doing and it's needed so I
love the mission and vision that you
guys have and so uh so grateful you're a
part of our community awesome thank you
brother thank you all right take
care okay coffee with canel what has
been your aha moment today so far uh
smash like if you're getting value a
couple questions came in we're going to
hit those and then we're going to go to
Stacy uh but as a reminder today's
episode is brought to you by V
podcast.com and
right now there's only a few hours left
to take advantage of a special pricing
and special bonuses including a ticket
to what's called our YouTube roadmap
Workshop happening in January how do you
like the idea of spending four hours
with myself Melissa Caputo from think
media team having uh the rest of our
think media certified coaches there and
spending some time putting together a
step-by-step plan for dominating YouTube
in 2024 well that's happening um we
actually will eventually have tickets on
sale for that separately but right now
at no extra charge you can include that
in um not just our video ring Academy
program but our camera confidence Niche
Finder course is all in one bundle at VR
podcast.com so if you go to the link in
the description or if you're watching on
Facebook or wherever VR podcast.com you
could type that into your browser and
take advantage of actually the best
offer that we have done this entire year
and so um this is definitely the time to
jump in if you've been on the fence
architectural sheet met ask can you do
an analytic review maybe take us through
your own analytics and help us read our
analytics um yeah we did a little bit at
the top of the hour uh I would say that
uh where do I spend my most time in
analytics number one I spend the most
time in my analytics in real
time uh this list of real-time videos is
interesting to me
because I'm curious what videos are old
hence video ranking Academy 2021 for
example and still getting views so this
video Nolan did got 105 views in the
last 60 Minutes 4,000 views in the last
two days and it's from 2021 so did this
one from Nolan now this is a 2023 from
Nolan so I spent a lot of time in my uh
in real time I'm curious what videos are
hitting which might influence what video
should I make next next remember success
leaves Clues make part
twos so I like to look in here I um also
like to look I did a live stream on the
think media channel more like a training
the first part was a little more
structured and then it was some Q&A I
like to go into the analytics to observe
how a video is performing is it
underperforming outperforming other
things is it continuing to perform well
subscribers gained Revenue Etc so I I
kind of look at videos what also could I
change in regards to that I actually may
change title or thumbnail if a video
needs to a pivot in my opinion so that's
something to look at I do study our RPM
just kind of curious where it is by the
way we just talked about the difference
between shorts and Longs and how much
they pay here's think media shorts pay
us 7 cents per a, views on RPM we got 3
million views made a total of 28
$15 our videos got 4.3 million views pay
755 for our RPM we made
$2,653 so compare 218 to
32653 we'd be out of business if it
wasn't for long form
videos we wouldn't I I we would shrink
down I mean I'd still be i' I'd be solo
out here I could we my wife and I'd be
making it but we wouldn't be supporting
the think media team if we weren't
getting our money right right and
getting that the YouTube money economics
right so um it's interesting to watch
the trends and the fluctuation of of the
finances um I really like uh probably
one of the most powerful things you
could do is look at this channel
channels your audience watches now mind
you this this area is not populated
typically until you grow to a certain
size so what other videos does your
audience watch shorts and lives and
podcasts
and what other channels does your
audience watch there's three pages here
um something to consider as far as okay
what are people into should I reach out
and see if they'd be interested in a
collaboration could I react to what
they're saying what what does this tell
me about the demographics and
psychographics of understanding my
audience is there a video topic that
maybe I should cover like on our Tech
Channel we might say DJI osmo pocket 3
um the new pocket throw I think it's
three Pro that is a video we want to
cover so once here's the osmo pocket 3
from potato jet the cool new camera by
the way seems to be pretty uh pretty
amazing one-in sensor um and so lots of
people talking about that okay hey
should we jump on that or maybe maybe
not but there's different insights that
can come from this area what time of day
are your viewers online um we accident I
I I actually need to talk to Kyle about
this I saw a video of go out on think
media at like four in the afternoon and
YouTube even said to us there was like a
a thing that popped up and it was like
your viewers aren't really on right now
it was like they're like what are you
doing I don't know if we just had to get
it out that day uh but uh it was like
posting if you're posting at four it's
literally like the lowest time for when
our viewers are on you could see right
here as opposed to you want to post your
videos before the wave so that's why we
upload it like five because we get these
F first medium purple and then
completely dark purple uh
midday and this is going to look
different for everybody so this is just
what it looks for US based on our local
time zone so as a rule we just typically
schedule upload our uploads at basically
5:00 am but um all of the that does
change it changes with back to school it
changes with the holidays so smart
creators you know like Michael Scott in
the office he's management by walking
around you know and what we like to do
is wander around our analytics h H what
can we learn what how could this
influence what video we make next should
our upload times change what are our
audience is watching who's maybe new on
the Block is there any Innovation we can
learn from um so great question there's
a few analytics tips the Swedish Car
Guy um think media team yeah I did plan
a whole video I made a script and
started working but I forgot to record
two-thirds of the video any tip
I forgot to record twoth thirds of the
subject um I mean if I I feel like I'm
coming in mid conversation here but I
feel
like if you're missing content for the
video could you always could you do a
voice over could you cover it with
b-roll or could you just re-shoot might
be frustrating but maybe you have to
maybe there is no way and the answer is
to reshoot the whole thing I've been
there A lot of times cryptic Jasmine
What audio recg and editing software do
you recommend for
beginners Well audio recording
software for beginners I mean I'm on a
PC to the dismay of 99% of the think
media team who think I'm set in my ways
and I don't adapt to the Times by the
way I'm an iPhone user and a MacBook Pro
user but I only PC is all that's my only
battle station which causes workflow
issues but it is what it is if I search
my app and I type in um if I search my
PC I I have an app called sound
recorder you want to know what I use I
use sound recorder on this is it right
here it works too when I'm I'm live so
let sound recorder access your
microphone yes check one two check one
two so I'm recording my audio right now
when I
do like a podcast with somebody on Zoom
or whatever or here's what I'll do I'll
turn this on and I'll put my phone
off to the side and I'll record a
vertical video when I'm on like a video
podcast or when I'm teaching and then
I'll give that to an editor with this
mic's audio recorded like that and then
just the onboard audio from my phone so
those two things could be stitched
together and now those could be YouTube
shorts or Instagram reels but as far as
what audio software I use there's a free
software called
audient um there's a paid software Adobe
Audition but but what I realize if your
mic is good you don't need to change
much because the sound recorder doesn't
really give you this this mic though
straight out of it's just this is what
it sounds like there's no processor or
anything on this so that's it and so
that's I'm just using the onboard free
software garage ban if you're on a Mac
is probably fine that'd be audio
recording software my question is what
do you need to record audio for Mo like
Adobe Premiere various video editing
computers
um video editing softwares usually allow
you to record right into them and and
they allow you to one of the cool
features is let's say you actually laid
down your b roll meaning your footage
your Clips all in a timeline of your
video editing
software then you can narrate the video
while watching it back so then you go so
today was our second day at
Disney what as a family we went on the
matter horn first then we got snow cones
and you just are talking about what
you're seeing what's kind of cool about
that is sometimes narrating a story
later can be a lot more powerful and
even more entertaining and interesting
and have much better audio than trying
to record throughout the day so
sometimes vlogging could just be mainly
footage based whereas you're GNA
actually tell the story
later anyways uh so that's some AUD uh
audio versions and then video editing I
think iMovie if you can get a Mac and
just starting with that is good Final
Cut Pro is not that hard so that's 300
bucks if you fil MOA is good Da Vinci is
a little more complex but there's a free
version of it not to throw a bunch of
things at you for
beginners use whatever free audio
software you have and use cap cut cap
cut mobile cap cut online cryptic
Jasmine if you want one answer cap cut
cap cut cap cut all right last question
before Stacy can you do something can
you do an affiliate on Amazon even if
you live in another country it's a great
question um simple answer is
yes personally I was born in the United
States that is where I live so it's not
a problem I've had to solve a friend of
mine Justin
lives in
Australia and his most lucrative
affiliate program is the US affiliate
program the Amazon us so
I forget how he did it but it's like you
sign up and then the money goes to like
a a holder entity thing that anyone can
set up and then I think there's a a
slight cost to that but then it
transfers the money and the check gets
like released to him so yeah it's the
same as I'm not saying it's going to be
easy but you can do business in
different count the reverse is true I
get checks from Canada and from the
UK for people clicking links and using
Amazon UK or Amazon Canada so you not
only can sign up
for all of the
Amazon like and and again I there might
be limitations depending on where you
live and I understand there's a lot of
privilege to living in the US so I
though can I am signed up for
Japan UK the different Amazons and Via
genius links one link will actually take
International viewers to their store now
disclaimer it's not necessarily helpful
all the time because I'll recommend a
product here and even though it'll take
them to their normal to their local
store they don't have the product or the
product costs 10 times as much so it's
like not as easy of a purchase
necessarily but not only can you be
signed up for Amazon that are outside of
your
country you can you don't have to
necessarily live in that country now do
you need to travel there to set it up do
you need to get on a phone to different
things things I know I'm not giving you
the exact thing for say Australia to uh
to us the way he did it but what I do
know is that many people do it it's it's
setting up those chains of how you going
to get paid how are you verifying your
identity how are you you know just
having it may be getting an entity of
some kind you know we have social
security numbers here you can get
business EIN numbers and and to that
level it speaks to maybe the scale you
need to be at
because you could probably set up some
kind of
a number or an exchange how are you
exchanging the funds um and it just it
may it may take an investment of a few
dollars to get it set up as my point um
so just being willing to jump through
the Hoops but if you do this stuff at
scale I think I'm talking about Justin
from Primal video he's made 10 probably
hundreds of thousands of dollars now um
in from the Amazon us affiliate program
okay we've got got Stacy I'm
excited so Stacy from Adventures gone
wrong welcome back to the show you were
on coffee with k a little while back
remind us about what you're doing and
how are things going yeah I was and uh
so I've had this channel for a year now
I've been on YouTube four years so this
is my second Channel I pivoted to this
and it's gone really well in a year and
when I was here last time I asked you
about going full-time when I wasn't even
really close to going full-time like I
was making a little bit of money a month
and um that's when we talked about you
know when you had said when I made about
25% of you know that magic number then
to quit and go for it well I'm now
making about 80% of that magic number
and I'm still scared to go
fulltime no but this is we got to
celebrate this is Cofe that is crazy so
and it's cool totally I totally remember
us talking and I was like you're way
closer than you realize yeah you said
that so it was how much do you need per
month to pay your bills and I said when
you're at 25% you go all in did you go
all in no no no I'm scared so now but so
now you've really supplemented those so
that means there's quite a bit of
abundance because you have your main
thing and this thing is doing 80% of
that so you have a little bit of extra
yeah I'm making almost double then way I
make it my full-time job too so but I
but the one thing I didn't ask and that
I was confused about was like I it's
been going well for two months you know
and do so that didn't occur to me back
then like how long should it be going
well for for you to be able to take the
plung like six months two months a year
you know like I know YouTube and I
mainly rely on AdSense I don't really
have much else going on yet but I am
looking into memberships and merchandise
and all the other income streams but um
so maybe I should get a couple of those
going first but you had said that my
AdSense would probably be a huge part
for my channel because of the way it was
going then and I'm getting lots of views
and my RPM is pretty good yes so I'm
just kind of I don't know if I'm I've
never run a business before I've been
I've had a government job for 20 years
right so I'm like you know it's great
talking to all the people in the elite
because there some business owners there
are giving me some advice but I thought
it would be great to get your take on it
where I am now yeah well first of all
congratulations major uh inspiration
from everybody here uh we're getting all
kinds of Love sent it your way and and
and super grateful I mean thanks for
taking action and punching fear in the
face because you know our mission at
think media is to help 10,000 Purpose
Driven people create a full-time living
doing what they love will make a
difference in the world with YouTube and
you're doing that and also shout out and
thank you so much for the Super Chat Eva
and thank you so much for the Super Chat
Luke got to 500,000 Subs thanks to your
advice thank you great job Luke Silva uh
grateful for your Super Chat and your
support okay this is a fun conversation
so first of all I know I said you know
go all in at 25% but the way you're
doing it sounds a little bit like how I
would do it which I like I like being
conservative I like
taking I lean on the extra solid path
rather than jump out when you like are
$1 when you have $1 enough of abundance
versus a little bit of a cushion a
little bit of savings to answer your
question specifically how long should
things be going well I think there's
something about having six months of
consistent results I think that's
interesting you said there's two months
so there's something about um seeing six
months the better answer would be 12
because there's something about learning
Cycles we can have a Black Swan Event
Event like c19 which is not even a cycle
it's a total out leer but cycles of
holidays cycles of UPS cycles of downs
one of the things that's been
interesting to observe is some people
are discouraged by their views being
down on YouTube right now overall
comparing comping it to the era they
remember of 2020 2021 when people were
so locked down and on their phones all
the time now we are really seeing a
return to shopping malls outdoors and no
doubt about it I mean YouTube is getting
zillions of views and shorts are getting
zillions of views so it's not like
there's there's so a lot of people uh
consuming but there was an ERA during
coid when it was like 10 times higher
than it was right now what's my point
the longer of Cycles you can see the
better I think also the better that the
longer you double your income like
you're doing right now the bigger the
cushion you can create and so I think
that's it's always incredibly wise to
have cash
reserves um to have a six-month
emergency fund so that also would give
you some peace of mind is not just to
have if you will doubled your income but
to have your monthly needed amount of
income six months reserved liquid now
you can survive Cycles because you're
like okay well half the year things are
really good to me it would seem your
subject matter is entertaining 20 you
know 247 365 but some of those
conservative moves would be very wise
emergency fund keep doing what you're
doing if you're finding it sustainable
how's your sleep and energy and rest
going with maintaining both it's it's
difficult yeah um I but I actually
recently um because I've wanted to get
more videos out like it takes me about
two to three weeks to get a video out
and I've recently hired a friend of mine
to do some research for me because
that's a huge part of it so that's
helping so I'm able to do that give her
a few hours a week and um it's making a
big difference this is the first week
I'm doing it but yeah it's like you're
running on both ends right trying to
keep the channel going and keep it
engaging and keep videos going but
luckily people are watching you know
like I don't post for three weeks but
I'm still getting getting the same
amount of views you know that I was when
I posted the last time so it's going
well now but I just you know you never
know if it's going to continue the same
rate and that's the other buffer for the
YouTube Creator which was also similar
to my goal earlier on we were doing one
of our coaching sessions and I was
talking about um
to Jenna that she should get five to 10
ranked videos um for you too I think you
know this two months old is still
getting 28 views this three months old
is still getting 50 views per hour this
five months old's getting 343 views per
hour
obviously we talked about last time it
would be nice if you could just do this
every time and print videos like this
but you are definitely in a different
position if over your next 50 videos 10
of them are have this kind of Baseline
if you had 10 videos working for you
getting you 343 views per hour we
oftentimes call a good YouTube video an
employee that you pay once that works
for you for weeks months and years to
come you have to you have to pay because
like you said you pay with your time
your energy it takes so long to make
these powerful stories but once you've
done the work if all goes well this
video literally works for you for the
next couple years paying you ad Revenue
even though you don't touch it
so the oversimplified answer to the
conversation is just keep what you're
doing honestly like it's entirely up to
you when you can tolerate how much
comfort do you want before jumping out
how much um you know stability do you
want and that brings me to I
think one thing that you could start
exploring would be this idea of brand
deals
potentially or this idea of asking what
business model could you connect to this
so I like to think about like like
um if there's maybe something you
personally love
um
and would get behind and let's say it
was something that was like paracord or
something like you know and and you try
to think about how much broad appeal
could it have so this is like a really
cool premium paracord handmade leather
camera
strap um and it so maybe it could be
some kind of a pocket knife it could be
some kind of a thing and this is this is
up to you right what I'm talking about
is what could you sell what could serve
your audience what could people that are
interested in maybe adventuring
themselves um what could something be
that's truly that you could be proud of
a friend of mine actually runs a company
that helps creators it's called product
as in like a product you're proud of
especially when you think about
sometimes white labeling lowquality
products
from um
AliExpress
versus what if you what if there was
something that was that irresistible
like oh I gotta buy that oh 25 bucks I
gotta buy that and imagine if so there
so when we think about ultimately
advertising on YouTube it's going to
come down to a really simple equation
end of the day no matter everybody
watching this is all selling
something even the people that are
uncomfortable with sales everybody
watching this is selling something
what YouTube has created is people
giving their attention by watching
videos and one of two things are going
to be sold maybe multiple things number
one if you go I just want ad Revenue I
just want people to advertise on my
videos you have to consider and this
would be very true for you
Stacy you're putting in you're making
many documentaries you are probably I
would argue you're probably one of the
lowest paid documentary filmmakers in
the world right
nowc because you're putting out these
Masterpiece stories of research and the
thumbnail and you're putting the whole
thing together and you're getting paid
on ad Revenue it's a big blessing
but the attention you're getting for
YouTube the
platform is allowing them to put ads on
your videos split the revenue with you
but the people putting ads on your
videos they're all selling something
they're they're selling a product a
service a car something so that the Deep
question that should may be trouble us
at night here at coffee with canel is
simply asking hey wait a minute why am I
not selling something you know at the
end of the day and and chances are if
smart advertisers were advertising on
your videos they would understand that
the people interested in your content
might be into Outdoors might be into
these different might be into like maybe
some natural living so they could buy
some bison meat that's dried and they
could have it shipped to your house
because all the nutrition you're going
to get and what are they going to sell
they're going to sell bison meat on your
videos Patagonia is GNA advertise on
your videos like whatever yeah Northface
was one of
the yeah
so so then as you evolve that's while
you're brainstorming you got a lot to do
to create your videos you've got you
still got the full-time job but you can
decide what is it I want to build and
what do I want to set up
because um don't underestimate for you
Stacy and everybody watching this
whether even if you're Chanel small you
getting any attention at all is
incredibly valuable and do you trust
your viewers you know in the hands of
advertisers well sure it's their
decision to make or or do you want to
serve them in whatever way possible so
again that could be merch it could be a
motto eventually you you put on a
t-shirt it could be a c you know
different things and you don't have to
launch that immediately but all I'm
saying is now you have Diversified your
business and it's much more stable if
you were to say Sean I'm going to quit
my job what's your plan add
Revenue there's people who are making
that work but if for some reason YouTube
got offended and they demonetized your
Channel or whatever you would you'd just
be in a vulnerable spot so it it's
continually asking the question man what
business model could I build around this
and there's so many there's a lot of
aligned products there could be
education related stuff there could be
travel related stuff partnership with
the travel company brand deals with out
stuff travel companies um you will sleep
more peacefully at night when you
know
you're
Diversified yeah I think that's it is
that's key and uh my biggest fear like
you said is the demonetization like I've
had one I've had a couple things come
through where they limited my ads on one
video and then I appealed it and then it
went back to normal but one stay so and
it's one that's getting a lot of views
right now so that you know dropped to
like zero Revenue so that's my biggest
fear and I try and really watch it I
don't know why that one got limited ads
could try and not post anything that was
it kind of because of violence or
because of serious well it was that
Mount Everest video and um in it I you
know people die on Mount Everest I'm
talking about death and stuff and at one
point I think I showed her body like the
person's body like it was frozen and you
know covered up and stuff but it was
being moved like really briefly in the
video and that's the only thing I can
think of that might have been offensive
in there but some of the stuff you see
on YouTube I'm like that's tame compared
to some stuff that I see so yeah and
learning those that all of these are
the we can land the plane here let's
look up the
definition of the word
entrepreneur so the you and everybody
watching this even if you wouldn't
consider yourself an entrepreneur by
simply setting out to start a YouTube
channel um that you know pays you
full-time um to be To Be Your Own Boss
to work for yourself here's the
definition of an entrepreneur it's a
person who organizes and operates a
business or businesses multiple taking
on greater than normal Financial risks
in order to do so there it is yeah so a
lot of us in general might
be uh risk
averse um you might say Sean I would
totally do this except for it scary it
feels risky yeah yeahh that's what
entrepreneurship is well I feel I feel
kind of Uncertain it feels like it has
less stability than you know if I just
stayed in my 9et
to-5 yeah that it this is the definition
like greater than normal Financial Risk
what is normal normal is the median
normal is the average the average person
does want to stay comfortable wants to
avoid risk wants to avoid doing
something different but ultimately the
person who Ventures out into the Creator
economy and by the way organizes and
operates a business so that mental shift
from just having a hobby channel to like
no I am a business operator I'm a
Creator CEO check uh chief executive
operator who am gonna organize and plan
and structure and think about even
though I don't know what it is what is
my product what is my sales what is my
marketing what is my business who does
my business need what kind of money does
my business need what will it take to
scale this thing and I'm going to take
on greater than normal Financial Risk to
do so um and a lot of times when things
start feeling risky uncertain unsteady
welcome to the party like I mean that's
where what we signed up for I mean
that's and
so calculated risks I think is a key um
taking risks but making sure you don't
bet the entire Farm because sometimes
you win and sometimes you learn losses
as painful as they may be can be
education in
entrepreneurship to you it might
be blurring out um you know something
like a body describing it like just
learning you know what how can I
communicate powerful stories but also
stay safe within you know YouTube's
guidelines but we're not gonna be able
to avoid those kinds of things there
will be videos you launch that maybe get
demonetized and it's super discouraging
because you're like I I lost out on
hundreds or maybe thousands of dollars
but maybe you gain 10,000 subscribers
and you learn from it like it's risky
it's the nature of things um that video
actually you talk about one video
changing your channel and that one
launched like catapulted my channel
because it brought in so many new
viewers and they all started watching my
old videos which why that femon old
video is picking up so it's really
changed the trajectory just that one
video and so if it's demonetized it's
it's fine I'm fine with that yeah it's
totally fine because that's a great
mindset to have because it's still
growth still subscribers which can watch
other videos and and the future is
forward any final final questions I can
answer for you no I think that's it you
you talking about the 12 month cycle
that's huge that I'd never thought of
that before but that's something I
haven't been through yet because the
Channel's so new so I think that's going
to be my plan is to do it for a year and
see and then I think I'll feel really
comfortable if I've been doing well for
a year you know doing it on just a
couple months makes me really nervous uh
quitting the job so I think a year's
plan is a great thing to go with I think
I think I think that is incredibly it's
nice to have a plan it's incredible from
this vantage point to look ahead and you
will have accomplished multiple things I
think the the other key and it sounds
like you're already probably really wise
Frugal disciplined but to be Super Wise
in entrepreneurship especially in those
early days keeping expenses low saving
money being Super Wise because
essentially you're launching a baby
you're getting you're trying you're
getting new life a new business a new
idea crawling walking potty trained
taking care of itself like the a
business is like a living organism so
it's like you're getting off the ground
but then when you got the 12 months of
experience and confidence savings cash
reserves momentum and confidence built
some more research done perhaps into to
even if you haven't launched it yet what
your next move is and your next move in
fact uh that kind of brings book of the
day to to my memory
uh I think that all of us whether you
read the book or not could say hey what
are my next five moves in my business
and patri bet David wrote a book highly
recommended it's called your next five
moves Master the art of business
strategy um so definitely a Source you
might enjoy and we'll link that up in
the uh show notes as well but just the
title itself is a good coffee with canle
question what are our next five moves so
you're like okay next move sustain this
for 12 months keep growing it when I can
and and then you also and save X dollars
so you're like you have a savings Target
because then that gives you a couple
buffers to just completely launch out
okay um and then also this all move one
research what other business business
models explore brand deals explore
physical products explore some things um
and and then you might actually put an
asterisk once you read one book on each
of the three business models that I
narrowed down to um and that would be
specifically if you wanted to how to
launch a physical product if you chose
that one you could learn about it right
and then it's like move to hire some you
know hire somebody an admin or you
already do research so whatever whatever
you think so anyways what are your your
next five moves for your YouTube
business for your content creation
business that's a question for copy with
canel Stacy I'm so grateful for you
thank you for coming back on and sharing
your story to see the progression is
super inspiring and um just love what
you're doing thank you and V and all the
V leaders out there that's an awesome
group I love it oh so grateful for you
and so uh give it up for Stacy in the
chat and um man what a story so cool
current situation she got her income
doubled still working 80% of replacing
that and uh really cool to see that that
is our goal for you as well I know that
we're all in different circumstances
maybe you want to use YouTube to get
leads clients and services for your
current existing service business of
some kind maybe you're a loan provider
real estate agent service professional
of some kind you want to generate new
business maybe you're trying to make
YouTube itself the business the creater
economy is the fastest growing small
business business type right now so that
is more than a legitimate business model
it is the fastest growing small business
model right now according to Yahoo
finance um and so no matter what we're
here to help you win I'm G to answer a
few questions but if you haven't heard
just so you know there's limited time
left to get into VR podcast.com if you
go to VR podcast.com what you're going
to see is we do have a special discount
and bonus package happening right now on
our signature online course called video
ranking Academy how do you like the idea
of having all of the answers to your
YouTube questions all in one place
really not just about how to do titles
and thumbnails and learn all of that
stuff but also how do you make this a
sustainable business inside of video ret
Academy is not just our signature course
that's about 55 hours long but you're
also going to get in this special offer
our camera confidence course our YouTube
Niche Finder course our YouTube shorts
Master Class AI for YouTube guide and a
ticket to our YouTube road map Workshop
that's happening in January this is an
offer we've never put together uh before
including all of these bonuses and
everything that's included um but it is
ending tonight November 1st at midnight
on the west coast um Pacific Standard
Time and so V podcast Link in the
description down below make sure to take
advantage of that and congrats to
everybody that's been jumping in if
you've been getting uh value today smash
like and if you have an aha moment we've
talked to three different guests we
talked a little bit about analytics
happy first of the month shout out to
Bone Thugs and Harmony and uh wake up
wake up wake up cash your checks and get
up it's the first of the month and I
hope you're doing well it's a good time
to look back what can we learn from the
past and from our YouTube analytics but
more importantly let's look forward to
make a plan for dominating November and
December and so any aha moments what are
your next action items what is your
next moves is anyone going to grow video
live we are barely getting the marketing
information out for that but it is
happening April 24 25 and 26 Las Vegas
Nevada the M Resort Grow video live is
coming back we're locking in some
speakers locking in the details but
simply Sherry I am going to grow a video
live that is my I for sure will be there
um You can count on that
what is your opinion of growing without
shorts I personally don't like making
shorts um I think it's totally fine I
think if your long
form works you should work what's
working um plenty of channels are
getting away without
shorts if nothing has worked yet it's
nice to experiment throughout different
content formats but if long form's
working yeah you don't need shorts
you're you're fine that's where the
revenue is that's where a lot of impact
is is it still possible to grow without
shorts yeah it is um I know it's quite
weird but how does anyone video get
recommended under other videos sometimes
it seems pretty random and not attached
to your
Niche it's a good question decoding the
algorithm um YouTube what they realized
is like they didn't satisfy viewers by
only recommending the same thing so
there is some
randomization where like if let's say
you're watching
farm videos farming videos and farming
Vlogs what they realized was if they
recommended to that viewer it would
maybe logically make sense their
homepage even all their different pages
would just be everything be like
tractors plowing fields and then it
might even be adjacently related like
cows chick you know poultry like
whatever but what they realized
was people want a break
so when someone's done with one video
it's not like oh I want to keep
necessarily watching farming content for
the rest of my life so if underneath it
if it's like another related farming
video another related farming video a
sports highlights
video um a comedian Jimmy Kimmel so that
seems like random but like it's also
broad appeal to content that they're
always testing and putting in front of
people now if me the consumer
man I'm just deep I'm studying I want to
build a farm I want to figure out all
the details I'm studying that they
recommend Jimmy Kimmel I don't click
they recommend Sports I don't care so
then they try something else though they
recommend the new Taylor Swift song you
got me because I'm a
Swifty kidding maybe am I
kidding but they they recommend
seemingly random stuff and if it gets
you to click then that
is a feedback loop to Amazon to YouTube
going oh Sean's a Swifty there's a
reason why post Malone gets recommended
to me a lot because I I actually am a
posty is that what you call it um and
they know that I okay I'll get clicks
there but then they also so then they
might recommend other like hip hop
trivia other things so that's kind of
that's a great question it's if you're
getting videos that are recommended that
seem random and not attached to your
niche
it's because YouTube is surfacing
content and what they're also studying
is they're like other people who are
like you or like your subscribers or
behave like like you also liked this
John Mayor song or this um comedian or
this completely this video about the
crazy the line city they're building
over you know in the Middle East like
just random facts or something you click
on it start starts being a feedback loop
uh where will there be virtual tickets
for grow a video live there will not I
can assuredly say with a
99.5% confidence level that we've
already discussed there's no virtual
tickets for Grow video live we will be
of course capturing the recordings I
don't even know if we'll release them um
but I will say
that everything we've talked about up
until this point is we want to guard our
Focus from trying to serve online and in
person um by just not doing online so
apologize for that but that's the plan
is there a quick one affiliate programs
available for editing
apps you know what's hard is there is an
affiliate program for like the Apple
store but I've never like gotten paid
so you you explained that to
me so uh does Apple have affiliate
programs join the Apple affiliate
program and earn next Revenue every time
a purchase is made all right so you can
look this stuff up I mean how does it
work join the program fill out this
application is this going to be for like
their MacBooks though and
stuff hey Drea hey Kyle why aren't we
signed up for
Apple um all I know is I signed up for
look look at this earn 2.5%
promoting
apps and and and by the way I can't say
I fully exhausted this topic because I
don't know if I've ever really ranked at
a crazy level an app related video but
back I've done a lot of video editing
software ones which again Adobe Premiere
find all more desktop based but I Al
like even Final Cut I'm like if people
clicked on my final cut link where the
heck's my money where's my 2.5%
Apple Apple better have my
money Apple better have my money okay
they don't though so so anyway look into
it you can study it out uh in theory it
totally should should work and um I
don't
know so uh if if you were to coach me as
we land the plane should I focus on
looking at my unfocused topics on my
channel super similar to Sean starting
out that you give me the most chance to
grow enough to have two
income so if I was to coach you looking
at the
unfocused so if I was to coach
you if you're basing it based on
like like you said you saw my channel
and you saw that it was unfocused and I
see what you're that you're doing
something similar in the sense of you
got like the ultimate book guide what
happens when you try to give a
narcissist a gift an easy 9 Minute
exercise movement be gentle and true
even to those who are suffering I see
what you mean you you are you were like
Shawn when I started of my
channel um stock market and index funds
for beginners the topics are all over
the place okay um we go back you've been
uploading for 13 years that's cool and
you've got some older videos that have
done well in terms of family and stuff
so it's really a hodg Podge um but all
in all you've pulled 209,000 views
so you do have the opportunity like the
way I talk about my channel
is interesting my Sean canel Channel
because on the one
hand
um even if I haven't uploaded in a long
time it's it's a quote unquote horrible
Channel because I'm like I'm writing my
wife love poems good idea by the way
that was that was a win um making
uploading like a sermon of me speaking
at a church 10 cool home office ideas
how to finish 2018 and 2019 strong okay
so in and of itself The Branding the
promise the clarity of the Channel
That's the the problem with it and I
teach on that a lot now
however it doesn't mean that along the
journey I haven't had tremendous success
with this Channel and actually made some
pretty good money so when you say
looking at the unfocus on your channel
what would give me the most chance to
grow income well if you master the art
and skill of ranking videos connected to
passive
income oversimplified saying getting
videos posted to YouTube that are viewed
for weeks months and years to come and
are connected to something like
affiliate marketing where when someone
clicks the link and they buy something
you make passive income and you get
paid then it doesn't matter if your
Channel's focused or not to a point
that's air quotes don't take that out of
context it matters if you want to
actually build a brand but if you want
oneoff videos that pay
well you can learn to rank oneoff videos
and earn money with them so if you
actually look at the history of this
Channel 20 3,000 views on a watch for
Huawei Link in the description above the
fold I sold wall W watches or people
clicked the link and bought a different
brand but because they were looking for
sports watches back in 17
2017 um some of the the biggest videos
on this channel were this CBD one made a
lot of money um this ye camera one did
uh well the green juice one which
will'll come up to
here did
$20,000 did I pass it I must have it's
like 100,000
views um let's see gadgets cool gadgets
for men around the holidays
78,000 oh here's the greens powder that
did 20,000 because of the percentage and
the continuity the coffee story so you
can actually see whereas it seems very
random from a c SE perspective back when
someone you know this self-improvement
book it's not ranked now but 268,000
this generated directly hundreds and
thousands of dollars of sales in books
but indirectly more because of that much
viewership and that many clicks on a
list of books like that so this
Christmas laser lights is an insane case
study six years ago I ranked saw the
timing of the Train the season Etc so I
was using this Channel and I continue to
do so to provide proof of studies of how
in different niches how I have ranked
and monetized all kinds of topics not
related to YouTube so for me it was like
it's was a place to do experiments it
was a place to do one-off videos it was
a place to prove that my seven-step
system worked it was a place to prove
that it's possible to earn passive
income if you're just dabbling on the
side around hobby type of topics these
are kind of hobby lifestyle type of
topics does this channel evidence
building a really strong and clear brand
I don't believe it does does this
channel have a real Legacy potential to
it well if I pivot it which I plan to I
believe it does it actually got
demonetized because views dropped um
just didn't hit the 4,000 watch hours as
I hav't uploaded in three years uh but I
actually did get a silver play button
because it kept
growing there's a whole reel that went
viral so anyways long answer to your
question uh I would
prefer you build a brand get clear on a
niche think about the Legacy You're
Building Etc but if
you just identify good topic rank good
topic monetize good topic and collect
the money and learn how to do that try
it 50 times have it work 15 and build a
baseline of a few thousand dollars a
month more power to you and it's
absolutely
possible as you really
Master the seven ARS thinking about
ahead of time what is the video does the
topic have view potential how am I going
to monetize it am I already approved for
the affiliate program see I I would be
hesitant personally based on my previous
Trauma from App companies not paying me
to just be like I can't trust I'm not
gonna go make a video that's going to
get a quarter million views not being
sure if Apple's going to give me my 2.5%
I don't know what happened it just has
never worked I've even tracked I logged
in my I'm like I got like 4,000 clicks
what do you mean but but what I might do
is I might go wait a minute if I go down
stairs right now by the way there's
always 50 Shan canel YouTube Channel
video ideas that I want to make there's
never not a time where I have 50 ideas
I'm ready to make at this exact moment
about like liver pills that I have in my
kitchen that's true um and and like red
light I mean I want to do like red light
videos because by the way so not only am
I a biohacker and and do I use these and
love these and they're red light do you
want
proof they're real red light therapy
like we've never welcome to the post
Halloween coffee with canel
Stream So Not only am I an active user
and believer in the powerful qualities
of of red light therapy
panels um
but I would personally think about how
do I how do I rank that what's the angle
what's the Search terms what's the
whatever what's I I did my re I've
talked to hours to benaz AI I watched
100 YouTube videos I read blogs and web
I could transfer all that knowledge into
a one-off video that goes on SE canel
and that could get 25,000 views 100,000
views Etc and be connected to an
affiliate program for the red light
panels Andor other Alternatives at
different price points um and so I'm
kind of breaking down a lot of game here
of how you could apply this to the own
thing that you're doing the reason I
also hesitate from that though is it is
all as cool as all that is is it would
be a distraction from things I need to
do in my business with our team with my
current list of priorities those are not
towards the top so I went along on that
question but uh good question and I hope
there were some nuggets in there and and
that's what I hope friends that you be
you're thinking about on November 1 this
is an important stream this is also why
um today's stream is brought to you by
VR podcast.com
like this thing's no joke this thing's
work this thing works if you master this
seven seven-step system which you will
do inside of V podcast.com you will rank
before I made a YouTube course before I
was a YouTube expert before any of that
kind of stuff I was out here making
thousands of dollars off of Niche ranked
videos around multiple different topics
over the last 10 plus years really
crushing it in the last seven or eight
years got multiple soour play buttons
think media podcast Sean canel video
influencers got a go play button for
think media I've just been doing this
stuff now we have the think media
faculty Geniuses that are committed to
your success um that want to help you
win and so if you are serious about not
just getting some views but figuring out
how to make a sustainable income and
build a real business off of content on
YouTube I highly recommend at least
visiting VR podcast.com and the reason
is um as we land the plane on today's
stream because the offer is ending
tonight and that's not like false
scarcity or anything at the time of
recording we have 12 hours and 45
minutes to get in to the special offer
at VR podcast.com so don't wait don't
sleep lock it in and let's crush the
next few months Eva I appreciate your
followup on the $50 Super Chat thank you
so much super grateful it's cool to see
your consistency and ability to create
content you dial in some of those
details the Right video connected to the
right way to make money connected to
ranking boom let's let's get some of
that passive income going what do you
think is the most valuable thing to
implement on your channel for
2024 Lyman I will be covering that in
depth on our road map
training um one thing I will say though
and I guarantee this is a essential
element for
Success if you're going to succeed on
YouTube in
2024 you have to actually upload videos
on YouTube in
2024 thank you everybody so much thank
you for having me I will see you guys
uh okay dumb joke not even a joke it's
kind of true but but I but I would say
that would be the most valuable thing to
implement consistency and by the way
consistency means frequency of upload it
means consistent message consistent
brand consistent energy consistent
quality of content being consistent keep
showing up keep posting keep getting
better with every upload but but bring
your aame put out put some quality into
it um and uh we're here to help you on
the journey friends we've covered a lot
uh this is the coffee with canel show uh
I don't you don't have to go home but
she can't stay here because we are going
to be landing the plane um make sure to
subscribe for future episodes like this
episode if you got value um today's
episode is brought to you by VR
podcast.com so if you haven't checked
out that special offer definitely head
over to the page you can read exactly
what it is read some stories of some of
our students and uh I really look
forward to joining um for those of us
that are joining us inside ra we're on a
mission to help 1 million Purpose Driven
people create a full-time living doing
what they love while making a difference
in the world with YouTube and so um here
for it here for you on the journey my
name is Sean Kel rhymes with YouTube
channel this has been the coffee with
canel show and I can't wait to see you
in a future
episode